and on the mound today
welcome back matthew boyd bo buchet the
batter three hits in this series
including a pair last night there's a
fly ball into right field and hit deep
this ball's gonna go home run bull
bishop
an opposite field home run for bo his
21st home run of the season and the blue
jays have a first inning lead got a
fastball up
and out over the plate
and bushette
sends it into the bleachers
there's the payoff
he struck him out
gives up the one home run but toronto
out in the first and the tigers will try
and answer start number 26 on the season
for jose they got to get him right he's
eight and seven of the 370 earned run
averages
ground ball the third smith the second
for one simian back to first there's the
double play so that'll take care of that
laid off single in quick fashion
and deals and a fastball in the inside
corner strike three calls barrios gets a
double play and a three pitch strikeout
to robbie grossman to retire the tigers
in the first two-hit day for bo
that'll bring up vladimir guerrero jr
there's a high-flying ball it's going to
stay in the ballpark reyes backing up
underneath it and
oh he's going to
tag or simian excuse me is
tag jimmy goes to third
he strikes him out
[Music]
hernandez fooled by the change up at 79.
that's a big out two away
kirk to center field
but due's got a beat on it nice job by
matthew boyd to get out of it jose
barrios returns to the bound so far he's
faced the minimum
[Music]
called strike three the runner was going
and that'll end the inning barrios gets
with you looking fourth strike out of
the ball game and tigers will leave a
runner we'll go to the fourth and
cleveland smith got hit by a boyd
curveball his first time up
it's this one high and deep in the air
this ball's got a chance get up ball get
first major league home run for kevin
smith
and derek hill couldn't catch that one
so he gets his first big league home run
that is a bomb
tries to go inside with that little cut
fastball it's 91 miles an hour and he's
ready for it that's right in his
wheelhouse
it ends up in the bullpen of the blue
jays so he'll get that first major
league home run ball back
tigers have two on for the first time
today for harold castro
goes that way again it's deep two back
goes curry hill junior and he's got it
just short of the warning track jimenez
faces marcus simeon beau beschette
vladimir guerrero jr
and there's a bullet into left field i
think that got past the shortstop before
he could move
left field
grossman backpedaling he's got it and
the inning is over
for joe jimenez we don't expect this
rain delay to last very long as a matter
of fact the sun is back out it's a light
drizzle right here at comerica park so
it could be a very short delay the rain
delay started at 229 and now it's 254.
see if the tigers can get on the board
here with the two-out rally in the fifth
aquila do one for two
three two pitch from barrios
strike three
runners back to first and second two
down the one-one on a one-hopper to
harold castro
he'll throw out maguire
and the blue jays strand a couple of
walks that's an error charge to kevin
smith see if the tigers can take
advantage of it
grossman drills one that's a fair ball
scope's gonna hurry
he's gonna get to third grossman digs
for second he's in there
first two batters aboard for detroit in
the sixth
hits this ball so hard thinks he's a
line drive out
and then he realized i better get going
here
and again he hustles and gets himself a
double
little tapper as bereas checks the
runner they got a runner hung up his
second and they get him hey dodie burris
was a terrific fielder and robbie
grossman made a bad mistake in second
base as he has picked off on a good play
by the pitcher see if hero can pick up
the boys here and get come up with a big
two out hit either team good with
runners in scoring position castro right
side base hit
drives in jonathan scope of the tigers
first run and miguel cabrera goes first
to third
well let's just hit harrow finding a way
with two strikes
to get the barrel to back to the
baseball and driving in the tigers long
run today
that's a really good piece of hitting
there by harold
castro so after back-to-back singles a
five-pitch walk that loads the bases
forte oscar hernandez
popped it up shallow right reyes on the
charge he's got it
that's just as good everybody holds
the one
ground ball up the middle
willy castro to harold castro
bare-handed
what a double play
that's incredible
[Music]
wizardry all the way around
willy castro to harold castro the bare
hand grab and then the backhand stab out
of the dirt by jonathan scope blue jays
bullpen has to hold on right there to
try and win this series if they can get
three more outs
this ball is popped up in foul territory
guerrillas got some room he gets there
and makes the catch
there's another slider lots of room out
there in center that's dyson who will
make the catch and
mesa gets the two here in the bottom of
the night
1-0 base hit to left
he keeps it alive
[Applause]
one two
little tapper towards second simeon will
go to first and that's the ball game boy
what a game for the blue jays they
needed this one to win the series
you